you know the alpha widow thing yeah like
for those who don't know can you explain
oh an alpha widow is basically okay
you okay you got a girl right yeah
she dates this one guy in college that
was the best dude she could do or you
know in high school could be katy
perry's high school sweetheart when you
say the best quantify what the best
looks like so the best is like what that
girl values so maybe she values like
money maybe she values ambition muscle
like whatever whatever she in like like
church communities it's like church
status like it's just yeah
so like this is the best guy i could
reproduce with
and she fumbles back
and then she like can't get over him so
and you hear it in like pop music all
the time like the one that got away the
one that wrecked my heart right i should
have never yeah you you know like
yeah yeah yeah but but you see that's
like there's so many songs if you listen
to female music it's like all different
versions of alpha widows like pretty
much okay like if you really listen to
the lyrics and like the most popular
ones go ahead yeah no no yes i was gonna
say just so just for clarification
a quote-unquote alpha widow is a girl
who's dated maybe a guy who was her top
choice and then things didn't go the way
she wanted and now every guy she now
dates she compares to him and no one
matches up yes correct right so
basically
there was this girl in college oh oh god
i think you've heard this story before
maybe tell us anyway yeah yeah so
she
um
when i heard like what an alpha would
have was she was who had thought of
because she dated this dude freshman
year freshman year guy was
he wasn't really the job type
he wasn't you know like
but but he was you know i guess
smooth i don't know good looking guy i
don't know like the
i don't know anyways not
not my not my thing but you know and
they they did it for like a month
because then he cheated
i was like a month you don't look
surprised
yeah because
like she wasn't special he was doing
that like
he was kind of like streaking did do you
know what i mean street but then if he
said he was going to be excused
if he said he was going to be he wasn't
i i wasn't there they i i transferred
into this school
so i i don't even i wasn't even there
when they dated i just know they that's
what everyone said they did yeah okay
fair enough senior year she's dating new
guy he buys her house
yeah like they move into a nice big
house together um
i guess i don't know who bought it i
just assumed he did she very well could
have i don't know but i think i think he
did and um
i went to a party my senior year
and it was crazy because i was in the
basement of the party
and i and this girl tried to gaslight me
too like i didn't see this but you will
not gaslight me i saw this with my own
eyes she walks out of the bathroom with
the dude from freshman year
oh and like everyone's waiting to go to
the bathroom and like like that's what i
was waiting for and i'm like god this is
taking forever and then yeah they
wow
the dude from yeah so she and then the
guy that she um
she
dated who's dating currently came to the
party like half hour later
wow but that's the thing like alpha
widows like it doesn't matter who she's
dating she'll but so here's the thing is
that not is that not more because i
understand the i understand the premise
of comparing every guy you've met
compared to the one you feel got away
and not feeling their match up i get
that but her actually acting
on that is that not more of a reflection
of her character as opposed to just
being an alpha widow yeah do you know
what i mean because if you're an alpha
widow like you don't have to act on it
like you can always
yeah but
i know females
90 of them will
well also it depends on what it is
because it's like you know you could you
could have had the top jockey in high
school yeah then you know when you're in
your late 20s you're looking for
something more serious then it could be
more
what you're looking for the priorities
have changed do you know what i mean so
then the guy in high school who maybe at
the time you felt would have been the
one who got away he actually may not be
your top choice now
yeah but that's it's like the genuine
desire though so she is the genuine
desire for the
guy from high school where she looks at
the second guy as more of like a
provider but are we so genuine desire
just are we just purely talking about
the sexual desire
partially um
because i would argue i would argue that
so if she's let's take a go in her late
20s she can settle down right the guy
from high school he's still really hot
and attractive but let's say he's
actually not done that much she's not
going to choose him you're right you're
right like he has to women um like men
must become women just their love for
who they are they say like no like he
has to
girls only stay with a guy that like
that's a bum for so long and then so can
she still have genuine desire for that
same guy if he's not
i don't know
alpha widows
i'm asking you you're the girl
you know i mean i would say like it she
has to feel like the dude she's with is
better than the one from before
yeah i think that this is i mean you
asked this question on your when i was
on your
podcast saying you know
would
would i would we rather a guy that you
settled for her or rather that she
settled for the guy and i think
yeah it's always best if he's her top
choice
but then her priorities change over time
so it can be like her chop choice at 22.
well that's why that's 28. well yeah
that's why they say that she marries the
beta and cheats with the alpha and then
leaves the beta after she's got the kids
so you gotta be careful
do you think there are alpha and beta
women in the same way that alpha and
beta men that's a good question
sword i guess they say there's alpha
females right the ones that are like
dudes
is that what you call us as an alpha
female um
it's just like when you see the ones
that are super masculine and like
come in with like their
kevin samuels would say like their dick
out yeah you know
um can you be alpha can you get a woman
who is
she's the top woman in her space because
she's the most
she emulates the highest level of
feminine energies and qualities
no that's not what i think of i don't
know they don't really use those traits
for those words for women so it's a good
question but i've never really
like if i think of alpha
i think it would it would be more
like she would be masculine that's what
i would think like quite dominant yeah i
guess which i guess quite a masculine
trait i hear that
um
is there anything that you know now that
you wish you knew when you were 21
um
yeah yeah well tell us tell us i'd
rather not
tell us okay tell us something that
women can take away from
um
so if you're talking to like the 21 year
old i wish okay i would i would go back
to 19 actually or 18. okay um
i just i wish i waited till i was
married
you you uh yeah so i wish i did that
okay i just think it would have been
like cute why why'd you say that
um
i don't know i just think it's like
better
yeah yeah i think it's like cute but at
21 it would have been too late so
she'd be like
have you ever given because you've got a
younger sister
um yeah and have you ever how old are
she don't mind me asking which one i got
three uh was the oldest
the oldest youngest yeah is uh 20. she's
20. yeah have you ever given her any
advice about me she wouldn't she
wouldn't take it she would take it what
about the other one
yeah i've given the youngest ones advice
um
[Music]
yeah i have i've talked to them about it
yeah what have you
what's